joining us now in the content entire
coaches corner he's a burns men's
basketball coach Bruce Pearl eliminated
the three winning his schools in college
basketball history during the tournament
and of course he joins the long list of
grown man wearing warm-up suits at the
final floor yeah yeah bringing the
energy here guard but the weight of a
powerful with you do you have any
basketball talent how good are you at
basketball no good no I was a better
football player better baseball player
well how did you end up a basketball
coach I tried out for the basketball
team Boston College got cut Tom Davis
was the head coach there saw some
passion some energy some emotion and I
didn't wanna I didn't want to just like
no means not yet to me right I know
that's not a safe slogan these days but
I know what you mean you know I mean
yeah and so I became a manager and then
I became a student assistant and then I
became the director marketing and then I
just hung on and my senior year he got
the job at Stanford and he asked me to
go with him and that's how I got my
start and I we've talked about this
where you were there with the the Boston
College scandal yeah point-shaving yeah
yeah but you knew nothing you did you
sense anything that was going on you
know there was there was times during
some games when some of our more
aggressive offensive players weren't
taking shots and then there were some
times when some of the players that were
accused to be involved missed layups
that they probably but you think I don't
know where can you miss that yeah so but
I had no idea there was any connection
along those lines it's just sort of in
hindsight you look back in you
makes you wonder but when you saw that
documentary when you saw the 30 for 30
like that takes you back in time and
you're you're right there what did you
think that that that guys were victims
that they were preyed upon in a lot of
ways as young kids and it's our job
as coaches and administrators to try to
protect them to understand these things
are possible but how nervous are you now
with just the advent of open gambling
now it just feels like this is almost
becoming commonplace in sports and we're
talking about college athletics as well
you know you talk to the guys about it
but you're right it would be the same
thing if somebody could get out our guys
and understand that you know what's in
it for them I mean I'm at the Final Four
I'm not exactly what's in my contract
but I'm sure there's a nice bonus in
there for being here wait you don't know
if I honestly don't know because you
know why I don't know I've not looked at
it I don't know I'm trying to separate
the two I really am I'm just in my own
mind going look I'm grinding I'm focused
on the next opponent I do recognize that
this is gonna mean some security for
myself and my family which is a blessing
and I tell my guys look I'm 59 years old
I've worked really hard for this and and
you it's coming it's coming
I wish we were able to compensate them
more now for their efforts I got a great
idea how about an annuity how about just
this as a rather than just paying the
athletes we have a much more realistic
scholarship than we did before which i
think is great and our family's got to
come to the Final Four with some travel
expenses I've been at times I've been in
tournament where we'd go and parents
could go cuz they couldn't for the trip
or you'd get there lose and they got to
go home immediately and it was but how
much money are we talking on Williamson
worth this year to college basketball
see that's the hard part is how do I
separate him from a point guard in Iowa
how do you separate him from a woman's
field hockey player at Iowa well that's
part of the issue is they're all student
athletes and they're all worth and and
so what's what's fair listen the
system's not broken I will say this dan
what was I on Williamson worth a year
ago in Spartanburg South Carolina
compared to what he's worth nine months
later at Duke you know he got the
platform he took advantage of it and so
and so the system's not broken I do
think we're working to making it better
by making more realistic scholarship and
we're looking at ways that we can have
the kids get more of a benefit than
they're getting right you've eliminated
the three winning schools and
college basketball history that's pretty
good somebody got to do it well right
right but but do you realize you're like
you're here at the Final Four and you're
working I know I'm usually here at the
Final Four calling you guys asking if I
could get a little faced yeah it's true
and it is weird to see grown men in
warm-up suits yeah but only here is it
normal yeah it may be the Sopranos like
that's about right
you know I talked to our guys before it
you got a look at the road to the Final
Four
and and I broke it all down because you
got to show them the path I knew that
New Mexico State was as good at 12:00 as
it was in a tournament and we were the
only five to advance
now maybe Oregon was a tougher 12 in New
Mexico State but that was gonna be a
hard first game I told him the first
game hard skinny wins the first one and
then I went here it is Kansas you don't
Carolina Kentucky but we're trying to
make history we're at Auburn we're
trying to make history not just winning
a national champion but getting to a
Final Four but look at the road traveled
and so I wanted a guy said we wouldn't
have it any other way
he's Bruce Pearl head coach at Auburn
you're 34 30
when it's all said and done is gonna be
fascinating right maybe not in that
order you know when they do those 34 30s
they if you could sign a deal tonight
that I guarantee you win the national
title on Monday but you don't coach
again do you retire by choice yeah to
win a national championship I would have
to find other ways to do this ministry
you know I that's what it is Dan it's a
ministry it's it's affecting others and
affecting kids and having effect on a
campus so my first reaction was I take
it because that means it to win a
national championship box checked I've
won one in Division two yeah and I'm
proud of that where is that trophy it is
at the University of Southern Indiana in
Evansville Indiana no see you didn't
even get it oh no I don't need to have
the trophy the trophy is just the
extrinsic it's just the hardware I don't
need but didn't you insist they build a
statue
you at the school now no here's what I
want here's what I want is what I want I
want them to build the entrance way to
the student section and call that gate
the pearly gate that's what I want I
don't want the court well done yeah look
at you well done I googled you the names
that came up I've known you a long time
I the first name that comes up is Bruce
Willis Bruce Lee Bruce Springsteen Bruce
Jenner
Bruce Boudreau Bruce Willis movies and
then Bruce Pearl so if I put Bruce in
and I google that
that's my bad you're ahead of Bruce
Almighty and Bruce Arians so you know
you got Willis and Bruce Lee and
Springsteen Bruce Jenner I mean yes and
Bruce Willis movies are you famous in
Auburn you know a football this is a
football state yeah
but you're still coaching basketball in
a football state yeah
people in debate whether or not we're a
football school or not we are a football
school we're always gonna be a football
school we're proud to be a football
school but don't ask the women's
softball team that cuz we win there too
and we went in baseball and we went in
so many others things and so all birds
are pretty really really cool place miss
Barkley called you oh yeah when's the
last time two days ago what are you
saying just that he's glad I'm his coach
you know and things like that but he's
been that way win or lose here's the
other thing I mean Charles is authentic
completely and he appreciates Auburn
because nobody appreciates where they
are in life more than Charles Barkley
Charles Barkley walks around going oh my
gosh can you believe the life I live he
openly talks about it but he recognizes
that if it wasn't for coach Sonny Smith
and Auburn University being patient and
yet holding him accountable in the
proper balance he never would have
survived he never would have made it out
of there alive he did and then he grew
to who he is today is a wonderful man do
you have your speech ready for Saturday
pregame speech it's always the same it's
passion poise and purpose play with
passion
that means we're gonna try to play
harder than Virginia if we can which
would be hard poised you know handle the
moment you know look around at some
point prior to when there's 20 minutes
on the clock and understand what you
where you are and what you've done but
don't let runs get it get a hold of you
and then and then and then our purpose
would be to focus on the process not the
end result how do we have to play to try
to beat Virginia and that's a daunting
task because they're really good once
the last time you cried I cried last
night over what I could cry right now
just blessed look at that look at that
stadium behind you that's where you're
gonna be Saturday on the sidelines final
four with an opportunity to play for
national championship it's a if I can do
it anybody can do it then don't you feel
that way yourself sometimes
oh I mean it's like sitting really am I
really of all the great coaches and all
the coaches that I've had such respect
for you know I'm working my way to the
or at least in this moment to the top of
our profession and it's my emotion is
out of her the the respect that I have
for the others and so it's uh yeah it's
it's a special special time Paulie I won
the bet I told you I'd make Bruce Pearl
cry yeah the eyes are watering as a
minute ear I know there's a tear no yes
right there oh I can get my director
mango not to close down your face tears
running down your face
there is hopefully they're tears of joy
always great to see it thanks for making
time we appreciate it all right we're
back after this in the Dan Patrick show
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]